Qui mieux que Fatima calook,
8e de liste militante associate,
pour aller défendre ces 1.000.000 de personnes en
situation de handicap
et qui, comme elle,
aspire au bonheur et à l'égalité
dans la vie de tous les jours comme au travail.
Oui, c'est cela que nous voulons voir demain
siéger au Parlement européen.
Parce qu'ils la connaissent la vie.
Ils connaissent la réalité de cette vie,
sa dureté, mais aussi les combats qu'il faut mener
pour pouvoir défendre nos droits.
Et bien c'est cette france-là que nous voulons
envoyer au Parlement européen,
celles des ouvriers, des agriculteurs, des enseignantes,
des féministes,
des travailleuses du raid ou de l'énergie
qui rêvent d'un monde meilleur,
qui dialogue
avec toute la société pour la faire avancer.
Et c'est eux qu'il faut envoyer à Bruxelles,
parce que ce n'est plus à la finance
de diriger l'Europe
et encore moins aux agences de
rotation qui étrangent les pays.
Le neuf/06 en votant, Léon des fontaines
envoyé à Bruxelles le peuple travailleur,
le peuple des usines et des champs
pour enfin nous faire respecter.